but our security and defense said it's
Deborah Haynes is in her song and sent
this report
City
the owner of this flat was away when the
Russian rocket struck
his neighbor shows us the damage and
weighs up whether it's a price worth
paying to be free
foreign
[Music]
who are counting the cost and keeping a
record including the remains of the
rocket that hit his building
outside more evidence of Russia's new
Campaign Of Terror after its occupation
was cut short
the Billboards speak of renewed freedom
but the reality is one of fear
more than 40 people have died in Russian
strikes since Liberation day on the 11th
of November
yes the Russians are out of hearthstone
City but they haven't gone far they are
just on the opposite side of that bank
and they're using that position to fire
rounds into the City Daily
for those who remain they're no longer
under Russia's rule but still trapped by
its War
Ukrainian authorities are doing what
they can to help
the mayor tries to pacify one woman who
says she needs medicine is life better
now than before when Russia was
occupying
you can hear incoming explosions
regularly in the center of town we've
been on this trip with the mayor looking
at different points where they're giving
out humanitarian Aid and all the while
there are the sounds of explosions in
the background
here they queue for the most basic of
handouts
it's a very different atmosphere from a
month ago when crowd celebrated Russia's
Retreat
it's very dangerous here is relative
problems here Elementary
this Spirit of endurance is captured
most strongly in here the maternity
hospital
Julia discovered she was pregnant during
Russia's occupation that gave birth
after the Ukrainian liberation
original
Rhonda
foreign
they're not planning to leave her son
but for those who've had enough this
evacuation train offers a route out
it's one Victoria and her two children
have finally decided to take
um
despite her grief Victoria is sure of
one thing
all this pain will be worthwhile
provided Russia plays no part in
Ukraine's future
debraham Sky News in Herson City